you're from Canada originally so you
know how bad our system is in Ontario
right now right like it's getting worse
like the emergency wait times like
access to care everything is just broken
so I moved like a year and a half ago
and I didn't go back for a long time I
went back in October and Scarlett got a
wicked cough so I was just trying to
find cough medicine because she wasn't
going to sleep all night and like
everywhere in Toronto didn't have cough
medicine I've Seen Her Health Care
System basically go from Top tier to uh
third world country and I was fan of a
couple years very sad but I think from a
high level it's just you have to
restructure the way Physicians are
incentivized like right now it's just a
reactive system you don't get paid
unless people are sick and you don't get
paid unless you see a lot of people so
unless you change that whole fundamental
system it's never really you know
changed